it's it's very subjective that we base
our
nutritional choices on how pretty or how
cute an animal is you know it doesn't
make sense you know and we're lucky now
we're able to choose what we eat right
you know like it wasn't like that a
hundred years ago you know the purpose
of the food guide until like 40 years
ago was to make sure you got enough
calories now we're in an age of
restriction so we say like i don't want
horse i'd prefer deer or i'd prefer veal
or i had chicken yesterday i can't have
twice in a row
like all this is a bit of fluff what we
do in a way because we're so fortunate
to have enough food to decide my friend
remy warren was on a backpacking uh
horseback elk hunt and one of the horses
fell down and broke its leg and they had
to make a decision they were deep in the
back country and they had to shoot it
and uh it was just wasn't going to get
out of there and
after they shot it he decided that
really
this is it sound was going to go to
waste so they took the back straps off
and they they cooked it and ate it and
anybody said it was a really weird
moment where like this is an animal that
was like everybody's petting it and it
was
you were you know you're riding it and
it just it was a working animal but it
was an animal that you loved and then
all sudden it's down and you have to
kill it and he's like well it's going to
go to waste he said it just felt wrong
to let it go to waste so they they cut
the back straps off of it you know the
reason i think we don't eat horus
culturally is really based ultimately on
the battle of wolf between moncalm on
the plains of quebec city
uh you know that was a decisive battle
in north american history whereas if the
french had won that battle everybody in
north america ultimately would be
speaking french
you know
they didn't win that battle
so british rule imposed so in england
you didn't eat horus by royal decree but
in the french eight horse the belgians
eat the germans eat horse
you see so that's what it is yeah it's
very old history you know it was mining
it was just a boat in an anglophone
world to eat horse and in all the mining
countries uh
half my family's from belgium and it's
traditional there because they'd bring
the horse and the mine
the horse you know it's sad for a horse
to live in the mine in the dark but they
wouldn't bring it out when he was old
you know they would just eat the horse
most cultures eat turkish horse you know
well it was a necessity i mean you
couldn't pick and choose back when all
this was
instituted we're very limited in the
proteins that we eat especially in north
america quebec less so you know quebec
is a very open-minded dining public very
advanced dining public very old dining
public and of course latin french dining
public
the amount of proteins that are served
in a montreal restaurant
are
numerous compared to let's say even when
i go to manhattan if me and you and fred
are in manhattan tomorrow night
say let's go have rabbit with mustard
sauce it's going to be a tough sell
we're going to really struggle to find
rabbit mustard sauce we're going to
struggle even to find uh you know let's
go have a couple slices of liver tonight
with onions it's gonna be very difficult
lamb neck you know lamb liver deer is a
hard tall order you know ultimately
manhattan or america it's a limited
scope of proteins beef chicken
so forth
whereas you know french culture quebec
you know we have all the proteins i have
young dining clientele that have no
problem eating kidneys medium rare
uh liver lamb liver deer neck deer heart
tartare it's not a thing like it's not
what other restaurant people are eating
it's just part of the registry you know
little girls like your daughters are
raised eating
you know the food that their dad hunts
and the food that their parents buy
some people have lesser means
eat pork liver raised on it so when they
see liver on the restaurant cute little
you know 19 year old girls that are
about to go out to the club later
they'll have a slice of liver you won't
see that in new york city or